[music playing]
Cameras aren't working, and
it's getting super frustrating.
This is what it's like
on "Life Below Zero."
Camera's already down.
Tough conditions all
around to film in.
CROFTON DIACK: No heat,
no power, no anything.
Argh!
Won't even turn on.
CROFTON DIACK: I've
fallen too many times.
We have bad winds.
It's just a typical
day in the arctic.
MAN: Making best
with what we got.
[music playing]
I built this
time lapse lockbox.
And what we're going
to do with this one
is try and catch the freeze-up.
Hey, how come I get
the heavy [bleep]??
SIMEON HOUTMAN: I love
doing stuff like this,
getting out there trying to get
like different shots and shots
that maybe we haven't seen
before, like a lake freezing
up.
[music playing]
MAN: Oh boy.
Let's see.
We might be able to pull right--
SIMEON HOUTMAN: So we want to
get some elevation, and then
a nice clear, unobscured view.
MAN: I think these kind
of specialty type shots
are some of the most
fun part of this whole
being involved in this program.
I just really get a kick
out of trying to experiment
and do new things.
And so this is a
big part of that.
Are you still pretty
good for level?
SIMEON HOUTMAN: This
is completely enclosed,
and this is waterproof too.
So in theory, it should be good
to go and be able to withstand
all conditions.
We've got a solar panel hooked
up to a battery that ideally is
going to keep
charging this camera,
and it can run for
as long as it can.
She's set.
She's going.
Now we just got to wait and see.
[music playing]
[helicopter blades whirring]
Could you drop me off
and I can jump out?
The problem is the ridge
is only like a knife edge.
I don't know how
adventurous you are.
CROFTON DIACK: What
we're trying to do
is set up a really
long time lapse
so that we have the
Yukon breaking up.
So we're just looking
for that bluff visual
that looks out over the river.
If you take a second look
at it and it doesn't look
right, then let's not do it.
Yeah, I don't want
anybody to fall there.
I mean, you could fall off.
Bye, guys.
Be safe on that
little knife ridge.
[music playing]
The safety guy and the director
of photography just left.
They're up there
right now getting
dropped off at basically
a knife's edge of a peak.
And I am really excited,
a little bit nervous.
[music playing]
It's going to take a
couple of car batteries
to run the camera out
so that it doesn't quit
on us because we only have
one opportunity to get
this time lapse.
And we think it's going to
happen in this two-week window
when the ice of the frozen
Yukon river breaks up.
Is my job this cool?
Yeah, it is.